hello everyone this video is a
continuation of my previous video on
things to consider before going for a
phd now in that earlier video i had
discussed various issues like job
prospects stipend marriage issues and in
this video as promised earlier i am
going to discuss the academic side of
things
wherever possible i'll try to emphasize
again as in the previous video some of
the specific issues which indian
students particularly face
now before we can go any further for
those of you who may be seeing my videos
for the first time uh i'd like to give a
very brief background about myself i did
my undergraduate studies
here in the mechanical engineering
department of iit kharagpur i did my phd
also from iit kharagpur and then after
my post work abroad i joined as a
faculty member again in the mechanical
engineering department of iit kharagpur
so it has been a long association with
iit kharagpur but more importantly what
i would like to emphasize is that
all throughout my career i've been part
of the indian education system
first as a student and now as a faculty
member and based on these experiences
the things that i'm going to share i
hope it will be beneficial to all of you
so with that out of the way let us get
into the question of what are the
academic side of things to consider
before going for a phd
now the most important and the most
natural question which comes to people's
mind is that
suppose you have been a topper all
throughout your academic life does that
make you naturally suitable for going
for a phd the answer strangely is no
i have seen
quite a few students who have been
academic academically toppers but
ph is a different game altogether you
have to really understand this
so
please do not fall into this kind of
thought that you are going that you are
going to succeed in a phd just because
you have been a topper now on the
reverse side of things also
you have to understand that
just because you have not been a topper
does not make you unsuitable for a phd
okay so that we have ample evidence in
our hand to
for students who have done fabulously
well in their phd despite not having a
stellar academic performance in their
undergraduate or masters
okay
especially in their undergraduate
now
uh
we have to also understand here that
uh not with withstanding the previous
things that i said
uh you do have to have a baseline
academic proficiency so how do you how
do you
know that you have this academic
proficiency the suitability for phd now
the best thing to do is to actually
discuss with some kind of a mentor uh
that you may have
in your in your local place like
somebody
some professor whom you can actually
have a her to her chat it is especially
important that this person can speak to
you honestly
okay so without any [ __ ] he can tell
you whether or not uh you're on the
right track or you whether you have the
the nag the the special kind of
mentality that is necessary for going
for a phd but no matter of disc no
matter how much you may discuss with any
mentor or professor
ultimately this question whether you're
suitable for phd or not
it has to be answered by you only after
some brutal introspection you have to be
absolutely brutally honest with yourself
and for that to help you along i will
ask you a few questions so you ask these
questions to yourself
so the first question is that whether
you have a natural uh
desire to perhaps go off on your own and
uh explore things academically like
beyond the confines of your syllabus
whether you have this uh like it's like
a dissatisfaction always with not always
at least sometimes with some of your
coursework that okay i want to go beyond
these things sometimes some authors and
some professors they say things like
this this is beyond the scope of this
course or beyond the scope of this
textbook you want to go and explore
those things on your own okay do you
have this natural knack
i say this
so so related to this i want to
narrate a little incident
so here at iit kharagpur we have this
techno management festival called
shritish it has been going on for since
i was a student here so back in 2008 9
or 10 one of those years okay so we had
a very famous professor uh called
professor claus von klitzing he's a
nobel prize winner coming down here for
for a breast lecture so after the guest
lecture was over somebody asked him this
question during the question answer
session that what kind of things he was
interested in as a young student what
kind of things he was interested in
doing in his free time
so usually when we ask these kinds of
questions in to normal celebrities okay
one of the mill celebrities so
the kind of answers that we really get
sometimes get is that uh look these
people say look i was just like you i i
used to
i mean hang around with my friends have
fun with my friends i used to
bunk classes and this and that various
privilege things they say
you know what professor clothsing said
cleansing said
he said that in his free time as a young
student he used to explore how to find
out the volumes and areas of uh
three-dimensional solids okay so he was
interested in that he did it completely
on his own in his free time you see the
difference
so that's the kind of mentality that
it's a different kind of mentality
furthermore uh
something which is extremely relevant
for
uh science engineering maths is that you
need to have a special ability for
problem solving you ask yourself whether
you have this ability or not okay what i
mean to say here is that and i really
want to emphasize this point is that
sometimes people mistake this
problem solving for something like this
that they will try and compile the
questions various different types of
patterns of questions uh compile the
solutions to that learn them and uh
depending on
what what may be unfortunately be
doubted as the
i mean the fault of the examination
system only the kind of questions that
are generally asked in our schools and
colleges uh some kind of repetitive
pattern depending on that they will come
out come out with flying colors because
they have compiled this huge patterns a
huge
compilation of questions and solutions
that is not problem solving okay problem
solving at its heart means that you sit
down with a completely unknown problem
completely unneeded just you and the
problem pen and paper uh
for hours and hours tackling the trying
to tackle the problem from various sites
uh maybe
uh your effort extends over multiple
sessions of
uh of your effort okay so if you have uh
this knack of problem solving uh if you
have if you find some kind of a joy in
uh in such an activity
then it is really really good okay you
you are on the right track of pursuing a
phd
in all of these things you note that
uh
unlike your coursework unlike the
examination kind of things that you have
to do
uh the things that i'm trying to tell
you
is uh
is along the lines of unsupervised
learning okay so all throughout your
life through your coursework people have
told you what to do
but the kind of things that i'm trying
to emphasize here is that what do you
want to do
when you are not supervised okay this
you ask yourself
so these are the kind of things okay so
now before i proceed further another
thing is uh something on the creative
side so academically also one can be
very creative even in the like the
rather humdrum boring dry aspects
of
various
scientific things uh you can find a
spark of creativity
okay so if you have ex experience that
if you have
tried to think of different ways of
thinking about
a known issue but in a slightly
different way that is creative
you ask yourself whether you have this
habit or whether you are perfectly happy
with just accepting what is written in
the textbook the way of present in
presentation that is given
in the textbooks are you really happy
with that
next
so these are like the technical aspects
of the of the academic side some of the
non-technical aspects are also extremely
important and this is something which
many students who want to go for phd
they do not realize and these are the
aspects associated with reading with
communication and writing
now when you go for a phd you have to
spend a lot of time reading okay and
when i say reading i mean reading long
form
uh hard
complex passages
okay so
uh
i mean there's a strange kind of
situation in many of our engineering
colleges and uh
science colleges what are
changing streams and science streams
what happens is that many of the time
students they just refer to
the slides which are given by their
professors they go through them
they prepare for their exams they do
some problems
and that's how the semester goes away
they do not spend
much time going through the textbook i
say much time i think it's it's more
appropriate to say
if that they do not spend any time with
their textbooks
now it is very easy for me now that i am
a faculty member to point an accusatory
finger to students saying that look you
do not read textbooks and this and that
and be very sanctimonious about it
the
uh but the truth
especially in the indian context we have
to understand that many of the good
textbooks
okay many of the good textbooks they are
written mostly by foreign authors and
the way that some of these textbooks are
written they are not really accessible
to
most of the students okay even if you
have access to a low priced edition i'm
not talking about the accessibility of
the book itself i'm talking about the
access accessibility with regards to the
language because there does exist a big
language barrier for many indian
students okay so everyone has not gone
to an english medium school everyone has
not gone to a posh school so there are
language barriers
so
and
believe it or not recently i was reading
one book and i came across
on a very familiar concept which i know
okay but it was
it was written in a way by referring to
an example
something called the slats of a barrel
now this term the slats of a barrel i
had heard for the first time i'd
actually look it up to what to
understand what they mean
so
sometimes these kinds of disconnect
between what they want to write and
convey to a foreign student audience and
what indian students have a tendency to
understand and what is the scope of
knowledge there's a big mismatch okay so
i wish we had more professors like hc
vermont writing even our
undergraduate level textbooks
uh
okay so uh what i want to say here is
that
uh
we have to understand this this mismatch
exists and which is why many students
find it preferable to just go through
the slides that are prepared by the
professors instead of reading to the
textbooks
but
that that is not an excuse for students
to not at all inculcate a reading habit
okay i emphasize this again that during
your phd you have to read a lot and you
have to read hard and difficult things
okay really really complex things
and not only that you have to keep like
multiple threads of concepts and ideas
simultaneously in your head
okay so it is that it is it is almost
like a muscle
okay so uh people who who go to gym and
these things they will be able to tell
you that that can like muscle
development doesn't happen overnight
okay so
you have to develop this slowly slowly
over over months and over years
so your reading habit is also like that
you have to develop that muscle you have
to develop that stamina that patience
all right
as i was saying so uh there's no excuse
for you to not inculcate this reading
habit maybe in your own language you
read some story books you read the
newspaper okay so things like that you
have to uh inculcate you have to have
inculcated okay if you have not
inculcated better start now okay if you
want to go for a phd
next
uh
so reading is just like the baseline
thing beyond reading you have to have
the comprehension you have to have that
and that patience the
the mental argument to actually
comprehend things in a in a in a very
critical fashion not only that you have
to actually also critically analyze what
you're writing or what you are reading
so uh
unlike the kind of textbook reading
whatever little you may have done
earlier
you cannot just accept things as they
are written on the page you have to
critically analyze them try to find out
the flaws in what the author may be
writing so when you're reading a
scientific paper a journal paper you
have to try to find out the gap that is
the hurt and soul of research okay so
you have to have that mental capacity to
try to find a flaws this this habit of
of questioning what the author is
writing may be questioning the very
premise on which the author is basing
his arguments
okay so if again if you have not
developed this habit try to develop this
on this note i would like to point out
that there's something called the
the gre uh so this is an examination
which students have to appear in if they
want to study abroad
especially the us
so uh as part of the gre at least in i
knew that during our time there was an
an important part of the gre which uh
had to do with the composition the some
kind of an essay writing and then you
also had to analyze a piece like you had
to critically appraise a piece
so that is a very very good way of
judging
this kind of a critical analytical
ability of the uh of a prospective phd
candidate uh unfortunately you know in
our indian system as far as i know we do
not have the system we only judge the
students purely on the technical uh
aspects we do not judge them on this
kind of a general critical analytical
ability i wish we could uh we could take
a step in that direction also
now
uh the next thing is communication so
reading is fine
comprehension is fine let's say and then
let's say that your analytical skills
are also up to mark
but suppose
uh you cannot organize your thoughts in
a uh in a nice fashion synthesize what
you have read and understood and
analyzed and then
communicate your ideas then it will be
difficult for you to succeed in a phd
okay so now and this should not be
like a discouragement to you okay
none of us naturally have this ability
okay i mean very rarely a person may be
naturally gifted as a communicator but
that's quite rare okay uh usually we
don't have disabilities so this has to
be developed over time and most phd
students during their phd develop this
thing but what i'm trying to say is that
you should have an open mind towards
this okay you should not think that okay
i will just do the technical thing i
will not go into this this this soft
skills development thing if you if you
have that attitude then you will not be
able to succeed in a phd okay and
communication is such an important thing
it starts with how you communicate with
what you are doing about what you are
doing and what you want to do and what
could be the possible difficulties as
you communicate with your supervisor
your phd advisor okay it starts there
and it goes beyond that as you as you
probably
have to communicate your ideas to your
doctoral scrutiny committee and beyond
that in conferences in various kinds of
presentations and if you go into the
academic client day in and day out you
have to have this communication okay you
have to spend your words
all right
the next thing is that writing
okay now
uh
writing is something which
like holds the key to how smoothly your
phd will go how fast you will complete
your phd and overall how productive you
will be in your phd
okay so no matter how great a research
you have done if you are not able to
write up your results if you are not
able to write up and communicate your
results in the form of papers
then uh it's going to be very very
difficult okay now
of course uh i mean
[Music]
the kind of writing that you have to do
again it will be long-form passages so
uh so this this this ability to write
properly has to be developed to the
fullest extent unless of course you are
going to do a phd in something like pure
mathematics okay then maybe you do not
have to write as much but even in
applied mathematics certainly in
engineering and the sciences you have to
write a lot you have to really explain
what you have what you're doing so the
point that i'm trying to uh
that that i uh want you to ask yourself
is
do you have this habit of writing now i
know usually the answer will be no okay
most of us don't have this habit of
writing especially during an
undergraduate days maybe on rare
occasions some people are interested in
story writing poetry uh
some kind of article writing but that's
those are very rare cases okay usually
we don't have this habit so what i want
you to ask is that okay fine
but at least did you enjoy
the things like pressy writing summary
writing essay writing back when you were
at school so it goes back to that okay
so those were the kinds of exercises
believe it or not which comes
to extreme use during your phd and i'm
not making this up you ask any any
professor uh who has guided students
he will tell you this okay he or she
will tell you this that this is
something which you cannot cannot avoid
you have to write things in long form
you have to express yourself
now
again there is a language barrier okay i
understand this fully
many indian students find it extremely
difficult to write okay but
uh please do not
get into the misconception that this
kind of a problem with writing exists
only with students who have
probably the disadvantage of not having
any training in english because i have
seen
many students who have passed out from
english medium schools who
can understand things very well who are
rational or sound of logic
but when it comes to writing they have a
serious problem okay so it is
you know what it is it is like
like knowing the mechanics of riding a
bike or driving a car and actually being
able to ride a bike and driving a car
okay these are like completely separate
things you you have to know actually how
to ride a bike okay irrespective of the
immense amount of knowledge of mechanics
you have unless you you are you know
that
so you'll fall down okay similarly in
writing you have to uh actually
be
uh you have to go through the process of
knowing how to write okay and that can
only be developed through practice you
have to you have to go through the in
that pain of connecting your thoughts to
the words on the paper
okay so uh
many many students find it difficult
okay despite uh despite maybe even going
to very poor schools they find it
difficult sometimes what happens is that
people who have had a very good school
education they are capable of writing uh
beautifully structured sentences
but
sometimes on the scale of different of
connecting different paragraphs they ah
they completely screw it up okay so
there's a lack of coherency in their
writing some kind of inconsistency
okay
so if you have this ability
great if you don't start
start developing this ability okay or at
least be open to the idea that you have
to have to invest a lot of effort and
time in developing this availability
that that have that open mind and people
who have not had the privilege of going
to an english medium school please don't
feel down okay grammatical mistakes some
kind of shortcomings in vocabulary and
all these things these are like very
cosmetic things this can be
repaired over time there is no problem
the more important thing is that the
maturity of your thought the coherency
and the consistency of your thoughts and
how you can put them in in writing if
you i
i assure you this that if you can if you
have developed this muscle of connecting
your thoughts this organized thoughts
coherent thoughts in writing even in
your own mother term or that of the
language in which you have had your
schooling
i i assure you you can do the same thing
in english also there will be some
barrier but that can be overcome but
that is not as tough as a barrier as
not being able to uh to make this
transition from your thoughts to your uh
words uh to the written word
okay so i've spoken quite a lot on
various issues now these are the things
which i think are uh are are extremely
important
now please note that i have i have uh
i've not mentioned anything regarding
the uh some of the personality traits
okay so this video is already gone quite
a long i i won't uh drag it uh anymore
so
uh you tell me in your in the comments
uh if you would like to have another
video on those aspects like uh the
ability to take criticism uh the
uh the patients aspect the uh the
the various kinds of other personality
traits which may be required for uh
success in a phd and uh i'll try to
think seriously about making a separate
video for that
but before i end i want to just point
out one thing that i have posed a number
of questions to this video
maybe there are
19 points and
if you see that maybe you are saying yes
to uh six of them and maybe three or
four are saying no doesn't mean that it
makes you unsuitable okay
as long as you have an open mind as i've
said earlier multiple times it's fine
okay of course if out of nine or ten
questions you are saying no to
everything then maybe seriously rethink
about joining a phd okay but i'm sure
it'll not it'll not be like that just by
the very fact that you are watching this
video and
since i have spoken such a lot about
analyzing uh critically thinking about
the written word or hearing what you are
saying uh i i invite you to critically
appreciate this particular video itself
okay so as a as a meta concept all right
thank you very much see you next time